jumping in so when you first met with
sci-fi about doing the series did they
ask you if you had like a three and
five-year plan or was it sort of like
you know what i mean like how much do
they want to know about your future
plans for the series if it were to be a
hit yeah that's a good question um when
i pitched which was originally to usa
but it was the same group of people usa
sci-fi bravo was all universal content
it's all the same sort of grouping
uh
i mean it's all the same under the same
nbc sort of cable banner um sorry so i
uh
yeah the process i had to go i had to
pitch
a lot of it i had a pitch very detailed
what the first season was going to be
and then and then a little less detail
in seasons two and three um but
you know i didn't have to have an ending
of the show or anything that but i had
to have a lot of detail for sure the
first season i had to break out the
whole thing um and then after that yeah
a sense of where it's going a sense what
the
you know where we wanted it heading
after the first season i think i think
that would help them with tone
and also to know that i i had a plan
um
what they either knew or didn't know but
is the case is the plan goes away
immediately like these things are all
organic growing
you know you get stuff that you think is
going to work and it doesn't work and
then you got to pivot or you get stuff
that you weren't sure was going to work
and suddenly oh wow you know like
wow asta and darcy are really good
together that's the thing now you know
that wasn't planned from the beginning
but in episode three of the first season
suddenly like oh wow they have great
chemistry so then you build that up and
you build up that friendship and you try
to find those moments
where you sort of take all the stuff
that's working and sort of
feed it
and then it just it takes you
in a place that you may not have
expected and that's certainly what
happened with this show a lot of kids
what what did you
this is obviously a show you're making
on a budget and i'm just curious how is
it in the writers room when you are
writing because you know you can only do
so many shots of the full alien you can
only do so many vfx shots so how does
that actually get worked in in the
writer's room knowing you have that
finite budget to work with yeah i mean i
had the luxury shooting the pilot or
writing the pilot that i had not ever
done a show like this before so i didn't
have in my mind these things that i do
now that like we we can never shoot that
i just wrote it creatively what i wanted
to write now once we got into the the
process of producing the pilot there was
a lot of stuff we couldn't do and you
know we had to pull it out but i'm aware
of that now going into these things so
in the writers room we try to push the
envelope we try to okay creatively
what's the best version of this
and the best version of this is we have
an alien a full alien
you know walking across the glacier so
then you get into the production aspect
and you see what you can do you know you
have a lot of these you have a balance
you have there's a fx budget you have a
timing issue because whenever
alan tudic gets into the you know full
alien makeup it takes a few hours and
you can't support that in every day so
yeah you get in the production um
process of it and you have to whittle
things down so you start
you
you start with an awareness of what you
can't do there's certain things like we
can we can't do all this let's pare it
down so we're not killing ourselves in
production um but you do push the
envelope you know this is in a perfect
world let's try this
and oftentimes you can't do all of it
but you do as much of it as you can you
do as much as you can practically and
then you try to you know clean it up and
post and do stuff with visual effects if
you know if you can't do it all on the
day
uh i'm just gonna throw out there but um
obviously you i don't believe you've
been picked up for season three yet but
how much are you already thinking about
season three and what you want to
accomplish
uh at this point we are
maybe two thirds of the way shooting
season two um and still in the midst of
writing that i haven't finished writing
season two yet i have spent
zero
time thinking about about season three
i am
scrambling to keep my head above water
in season two
have not thought of it one bit to be on
i mean
that's not a hundred percent true
actually because
so you were live in the interview i get
it i get it no no the truth is as you
arch out these characters and we we are
in the process of working out like
what's the end of season two you have to
have some awareness of do we really want
to end them here because then season
three if we get one would be like this
we don't want to do that so you have a
bit of an awareness of like
what might be a good setup for for a
season three what might not be without
really knowing what the details of
season three might be but you do
there is an awareness in the room now
that we talk about it of
what's the jumping off point in the
season three because that's where you're
ending them in season two and is this
where we want to end harry in season two
because if we do that means season three
will be this and is that
am i going to get to season three and
say god i wish we hadn't done that so
there's an awareness of it you want to
set yourself up for success in the next
season so you want to end the characters
in an exciting fun place so that you
have
you know again without knowing what the
details would be in the future at least
you have a general sense of like oh that
could be cool to explore that in a new
season
i'm assuming season two is ten episodes
uh season two is not ten episodes season
two
is uh is more than ten episodes we did
ten last year we uh the season the first
half of season two is eight episodes
i think the plan is
a lot depends on covet you know but it's
split into two halves the first half
will be eight the second half i think
hopefully will be eight um
it's a weird world right now so there's
no guarantees of what's going to happen
but the plan is to do
is to do 16.
knowing that it was supposed to be 16
episodes did you write episode 8 as a
almost mini finale
yes
yeah it was a it was
the most difficult part of this season
um
structurally was going from a 10 episode
season to a longer season and it's a
different thing it's not you know 10 is
there's a reason that these cable shows
compress there's there's so much more
going on in 10 episodes the problem you
have more episodes is you run the risk
of treading water for a while
so what we tried to do was split that
chunk if we are we do do 16 split it
into halves
and then the first eight would build to
a mid-season finale
that would you know be a bit of a
cliffhanger but not like the end of the
season but and we do have a good one so
the first eight does have a bit of a
cliffhanger and then the second eight
builds
um
to something you know even bigger
uh and and but thematically both halves
are
are connected the the character arcs
although they may be arced out for each
half the overall arc of each character
spans the whole amount of time so it's
very tricky to do but i think we we
figured it out
i i have to stop i'm uh because they
they gave me the thing but i'll just say
that i uh uh yeah if you're doing eight
episodes and you just you're writing it
almost like as a mini season you know
but yeah
everything's going
everything's going crazy thank you so
much i really enjoy the show thanks
steve appreciate it